traut sich etwas was sich seit der
Pandemie in Peking nur ganz wenige
trauen
er geht ohne Maske nach draußen
eishacken mit seinem Sohn auf dem
zugefrorenen lianga-fluss
die chinesische Regierung hat alles
richtig gemacht
früher war das Corona-Virus gefährlicher
es hat die Lunge angegriffen
jetzt ist es nur noch ein Erkältung
oder es sind die Worte der
Staatspropaganda die die abrupten
Öffnungen rechtfertigen sollen am 7
Dezember stufte die Regierung die
Pandemie herab zu einem grippalen Infekt
doch diese angeblich harmlose Erkältung
mit Fieber stellt das chinesische
Gesundheitssystem gerade vor eine
Zerreißprobe in einem Social media-video
erzählt Klinik Arzt Dr Zang dass er am
Anschlag ist eigentlich sollte ich heute
keinen Dienst haben aber einer der Ärzte
ist zusammengebrochen und ich musste den
Dienst übernehmen wir hatten bislang
zwei Ärzte die wegen Erschöpfung
ausgefallen sind und jetzt sind es schon
drei
zu 100% überprüfen lassen sich diese
Hilferufe nicht doch es werden immer
mehr die Überlastung wird auch bei
unserem Dreh in einer fiberklinik in
Peking deutlich wir werden wenig
beachtet können ungestört drehen wir
sehen unzählige Patienten die auf dem
Krankenhaus fluchen behandelt werden
jedes Bett ist belegt einige Kranke
meist in hohem Alter atmen nur noch
schwach in diesem Zustand sei ihre
Überlebenschance nur noch gering
erfahren wir in den Behandlungsräumen
werden immer wieder Röntgenbilder
analysiert Diagnose Lungenentzündung
die meisten Patienten im Krankenhaus
sind ältere Menschen meist über 60 Jahre
viele mit Vorerkrankungen und ungeimpft
die Sterblichkeitsrate ist sehr hoch
in den offiziellen Statistiken tauchen
die vielen Toten nicht auf seit Pandemie
beginnt zählte Chinas
Gesundheitskommission etwas mehr als
5.000 Kurve tote Experten des
datenverarbeiters erfindet die in London
gehen von bis zu 16.000 Toten aus jeden
Tag und 2,5 Millionen Menschen stecken
sich demnach täglich neu an
Chinas Staatsführung veröffentlicht gar
keine infizierten zahlen mehr und doch
arbeiten die Krematorien hierzulande
rund um die Uhr Bilder von langen
Autoschlangen Bilder von unzähligen
Leichen auf Kliniken Bilder von
behelfsmäßigen pappsägen die mit roten
Tüchern bedeckt wurden sie
widersprechende offiziellen Darstellung
verdrängt die harte corona-realität er
denkt lieber an die neuen Freiheiten
stolz zeigte uns seinen Motorradclub
dieses Jahr wird gut sagt er endlich
wieder Reisefreiheit in China und auch
schon hat Pläne er will mit seiner
Familie nach Thailand fliegen
es ist gut für die Kinder
wir müssen mal rauskommen und die Welt
sehen
und dann fügt er noch hinzu die
Wirtschaft kommt wieder in Schwung das
ist sehr wichtig
und die Staatsführung steht massiv unter
Druck vor kurzem hat die Weltbank ihre
Prognose für das Wirtschaftswachstum der
Volksrepublik für dieses Jahr halbiert
von rund acht auf nur noch vier Prozent
ein warensignal und ein Grund warum
Chinas nullkovic
die Folgen bekam auch jennantu zu spüren
sie leitet eine salsa-tanzschule während
der Pandemie musste sie immer wieder
monatelang schließen zwei Tanzlehrer hat
sie verloren einer hatte gekündigt weil
er Angst hatte sich zu infizieren den
zweiten musste sie entlassen aus
Kostengründen die letzten drei Jahre
waren hart unsere Miete stieg um 15% und
jetzt haben wir nur noch zwei statt vier
Lehrern die Tanzschule ist nicht mehr so
attraktiv für die Schüler
immerhin seit zwei Wochen dürfen die
Tanzkurse wieder in Präsenz stattfinden
die meisten ihrer Schüler hatten bereits
Corona erzähltü einige Husten noch immer
wieder müssen sie beim Training eine
Pause einlegen in den Nachrichten wurde
verkündet dass man nach einer
corona-infektion einen Monat lang keinen
Sport machen soll und jetzt bleiben auch
bei uns die Schüler
ausgeben kommt für Ski aber nicht in
frage sie schaltet Werbung auf den
sozialen Medien
[Musik]
aber auch kreative challenges
sie hofft dass sich ihre Tanzkurse bald
wieder füllen
Schritt für Schritt kehrt in Peking
wieder Leben auf die Straßen zurück und
auch die Studierenden dürfen endlich
wieder in Bars erst seit September
vergibt China wieder Studenten Visa
wenig später kam Felicia Podolski in
Peking an ich bin damals wirklich unter
so erschwerten Umständen hier nach China
eingereist habe vier PCR-Tests gebraucht
habe insgesamt 15 Tage Quarantäne hinter
mir und wirklich jetzt hier zu stehen in
der Innenstadt und einfach zu sehen dass
Menschen rausgehen das war es gefühlt
sind das ist wirklich schön sehr schön
Felicia Podolski und ihre Kommilitonen
absolvieren einen internationalen
business-studiengang in Peking
Massentests Lockdown dann die Proteste
gegen die corona-politik Felicia hat
alles miterlebt von
nullcovert auch an der Uni steckten sich
die meisten an langsam App die erste
winterwelle in der Stadt ab merkt wie
sich das Leben hier langsam verändert am
Anfang ich kann mich noch erinnern ins
Stadtzentrum habe ich 20 Minuten mit dem
Taxi gebraucht mittlerweile brauche ich
eine Stunde aufgrund des vielen Verkehrs
die neuen Freiheiten haben ihre
Schattenseiten denn während viele in
chinas Hauptstadt das Ende der
lockdown-zeit feiern verbreitet sich das
Virus ungebremst im Land
[Musik]